peru has been plunged into its biggest
constitutional crisis in decades
following the resignation of its interim
president after just
five days in office manuel moreno agreed
to step down
after his short term was marked by
deadly unrest that prompted half his
cabinet to resign
people took to the streets of the
capitol lima to celebrate mourinho's
resignation
he took over the top job after
legislators voted to oust his popular
predecessor over corruption allegations
protesters say that move amounted to a
parliamentary
coup arena made the announcement
that he was stepping down in a short
televised address
at this moment when the country is going
through one of its greatest political
crises
i want to announce to all the country
that i present my irrevocable
resignation of the post of the
presidency of the republic
i call for the peace and unity of all
peruvians
my commitment is to peru
our correspondent johann ramirez is out
on the streets covering the story for us
in lima
we asked him about reactions there
here's what happened
yes uh we have seen thousands of people
since uh we knew about the resignation
of manuel marino
thousands of people
[Music]
and this is you can see this is a part
to hear a celebration
last night
the words party and celebration did come
through they're
hard to understand exactly what our
correspondent was saying but dw's javi
agidis is with us here in the studio to
put it into context
for us good to see you javier so
jubilation there in the streets of
lima is there really much to celebrate
in peru right now
well not really terry what people are
celebrating is
the simple fact that the population was
able
to not let what parliament was trying to
do
happen that easily without any
consequences and it is simply
the fact that they impeached the
president martin biscarra
who was in power because he was the vice
president of
another president that had to resign due
to corruption allegations
this just to give you a brief idea of
the scope of the problem that is going
on in peru
they basically have every single
politician somehow accused
of very bad corruption scandals and
this is what led to a power
struggle between parliament and the
president
martin viscara actually not the one that
just resigned but the one before him
who wanted to fight that corruption now
manuel merino the president who just
resigned
was in charge of parliament he was the
president of the parliament and had to
take over
after martin viscara was impeached but
the population was so angry
by seeing this power struggle and
politicians simply adhering to power for
the sake of it not really
because anyone was seriously fighting
corruption that they took to the streets
and it was effective now manuel medina
had to resign
and that's the situation we're in right
now okay
the impeachment process aside we don't
really
you know it's hard to get through the uh
allegations right now of
what happened but why did mourinho's
appointment uh this was a parliamentary
process
you know there wasn't a you know it
wasn't a coup in in a traditional sense
why was why did his resign why did his
appointment cause such outrage
well it's because martin viscara was
very popular among peruvians because he
wanted to fight corruption
and once they accused the parliament
accused
biscara as well of allegedly having been
corrupt when he was
uh in a regional government in the past
um
they simply made that impeachment and
placed the president of parliament
who had been fighting martin biscarra
very often
in power as the president the problem is
once he was there
he named uh the cabinet of this new
government
including many members of congress and
of parliament who are themselves
being investigated for corruption so it
is i mean it sounds ridiculous
but it is really a a circus if you will
in in
a in a way and that's why people are so
angry and it's easy to understand
it's very complex okay just just one
question
any idea who's going to replace who's
going to come in next as prime minister
we don't really know right now because
there was a parliamentary session where
the parliament was going to name a new
president of that parliament who would
then assume and take over the functions
of the executive
but that session had to be postponed and
it will continue
on monday afternoon peruvian time so we
will definitely
see a lot more going on improve the next
few days perhaps a new prime minister
before the end of the day who knows okay
avi argued thank you so much